[Music]
what's going on reject nation Greg outta
here Jean here found out Avengers
infinity war how it should have ended
has done its take on it I'm excited for
that before we go into this I want to
give a patron of the day shout out to
Norval Jeff Lloyd Novell we had a Google
hangout with your recently buddy you are
killing it in the Las Vegas scene women
are crawling after you left and right I
can see why cuz when you just slightly
curl up your arm for no reason I can see
that bulge in your arm and I'm sure when
you stand
I'll see you even bigger bulge you are a
handsome man you have sent us the link
to your movie this guy's made like four
movies no your intro active and for some
reason he's supporting us when it should
be in Reverse and this is our reverse
way of doing it shouting you out in this
video keep a look out for this guy
Novell Jeff Lloyd because he's gonna be
a superstar and same work ethic insane
charm insane bulges all over his body
insane mental state well here we are the
location of the soul stone is right in
there
I guess you better go in and get it this
is a lake of acid walk on in and get
that Stoney beat so bad it's all the way
at the crap that's crazy you must have
heard the bubbles I mean I wouldn't lie
to you your sister did it to us at one
job this does not go
[Music]
bumper
[Music]
and big is here
[Applause]
epicness
[Music]
[Music]
you're right I just went forward in time
to see all the possible outcomes well
how many did we win fine
oh yeah you're much more than that
what'd they take it was dead
Wow do we we already
[Music]
baby care of them we can't just leave
him here
hey honey remember that dream I was
talking about say hello to our new son
Thanos oh come on this is not the
weirdest thing I brought over tell me
you didn't do it no you did is there
anyone else not using their hands at the
moment that could shut him up thank you
[Music]
[Music]
all the comics yes no no no I don't
think so
I'll be taking that those worry everyone
I've got this
[Music]
okay for this
[Music]
you know I was thinking the exact same
thing knocks the rabbit gave me a new
eyeball from his buttocks the rightful
king of Asgard which is now earth by the
way I forgot to mention that so I
suppose ya earth doesn't work like that
I'm afraid
well I new Infinity Gauntlet beg to
differ
I will follow the majestic pirate angel
man anywhere well I won't hey jerkface
my girlfriend died for your precious
gauntlet well you guys we finally made
it even right look at us
everyone's here the Guardians Spider Man
sure even made a new vision Thank You
vibranium yeah everyone's here except
Hawkeye and the Netflix Avengers and
[Music]
okay except those guys we're all here
though
we want the day what are you talking
about we always win this is like every
summer for us can you imagine if we
actually lost
I just became the king of Wakanda toast
here's to the greatest team in the whole
universe to a couple of Tagalongs who
are pretty awesome as well yeah yeah are
you talking about us
I'm not a tag-along I was here first
yeah if anything you guys are on my
third wheel do you know why he's a
teenager
you didn't care about anything right now
well I guess I would leave stop hey
remember when we had that Civil War and
wanted to kill each other for nothing
[Laughter]
[Music]
remember when remember when Bruce had a
different face remember when Black Widow
made me believe we had a future together
remember when I say it the world from
Dormammu without any of you don't make
up stories straight
I'm not making it remember when I killed
Tony's parents okay with that you want
arm Jesus Haman
my name's coop and this is my very good
friend here meek we're gonna go to that
jukebox over there and play some music
[Music]
what did you just do oh I feel itchy
Oh on your feet old man this is no ghost
[Music]
yeah are you happy now - yes I thought
it was the only world Joker I don't feel
so good I don't want I don't want to go
I don't want to go Joker
please it's okay Loosli I play one
[Music]
[Music]
right
it's
[Music]
Wow
Wow John Bailey there's one the main
voices on it I was wondering yeah hello
everyone I'm back have I got a story for
you and picked my own death again what
is this where is everyone
epic oh man yeah epic epic stuff right
there pretty much every one of those is
a good idea yeah the funny thing is I
just watched Doctor Strange again like a
couple days ago the whole mirrored
dimension thing I was like oh yeah yeah
let's try that I actually thought this
how it should have ended had a really
cool narrative to it yeah Doctor Strange
there make you find a Doctor Strange and
how he sees only one outcome and he says
five and then he goes one are we gonna
see five different and yeah that's
pretty clever for what how it should
have been it is and how they always do
multiple how it should have ended yeah
and then when you watch them play out
you're like that's actually a good idea
I mean the first one alone where he just
see their hundreds up that could have
been a foreshadowing moment it would
have been very anti-climatic in a sort
of way on the same with the other one
with the head the time stone just
turning it back much lack year but it's
gonna work these things could have
worked and I thought like there was
actual narrative to what they were doing
here even with Tony Stark bringing home
a baby I got baby Dennis as silly as it
is in the no way it would have worked in
live-action
it still is a narrative that's bringing
a full circle from what was talked about
at the beginning of the room each one
becomes its own little micro sketch it's
silly the way she gets the glove Nebula
but when I saw that for a second I'm
like this is kind of cool yeah it's not
funny at all actually
but it's kind of cool yeah that would
have actually been a knee moment to see
like maybe not for this iteration yeah
any movie but you know like in an
alternate world that would have been
cool because it fit any gauntlet comic
book she does get the gauntlet towards
like the ending of the book it was kind
of neat to see it actually happened and
yeah I loved the narrative of how they
told a story here
ow damn it it was more than just making
fun of the ending when they're all
gathered around the table and they're
all bantering in fact it's giving you
the infinity war moment you kind of
would have wanted which is seeing all
these characters actually write to it
each other and try them together that's
like a sappy ending and they're all just
reminiscing of look how far we've come
look at home get all this stuff we've
accomplished won all the jokes that they
brought like I really appreciated the
writing in this episode especially
because this is the different banter and
the callbacks they're making different
Marvin was still within character yeah
totally and I and I admire that about
them as like you can tell that there was
a love and they do take you know the
characters a little bit serious yeah
even though this is wacky playing out
the whole disintegration thing in
Reverse having them all get emotional
about it
it was really funny and it was it was I
was actually genuinely surprised by this
sometimes I break into like a musical
number rare is it were I'm like whoa you
you did a story here you told five
different endings and it made sense for
the narrative of Doctor Strange going
yeah seeing all the different endings
happen you know what more can you really
say this is some clever stuff that was
written in here and that's even like the
tease of like Deadpool and I'm like that
would have been as sweet those credits
yeah
I mean we're getting Deadpool this makes
no sense in this singer but nowhere
that's cool I will watch him go up
against that if anybody could do it it's
the fourth wall breaker yeah because
that's one power Thanos doesn't have he
can't break the fourth wall
it's funny how tuned sandwich had young
Thanos and like elementary school okay
have babies yeah they got a collab
someday and make it look a little like
then I was growing up schedule something
I thought this is very creative and I
thought it honored the Avengers in a
nice spoof fashion it was more than just
going
this is stupid it didn't do that if they
think it was honoring it and which I
thought paying homage you know in a
really clever way and that's how silly
to say cuz like that's what how it
should amend its job it's essentially is
with these but more so than any other
video this felt like they were honoring
it and even honoring how much how it
should have ended has thrived off of
spoofing stuff like the Avengers oh yeah
you feel that vibe too in a way
I was thinking this kind of feel
could be how it should have ended
goodbye episode feels like you've come
on a journey with them even though all
the videos aren't connected or anything
like that but yeah you realize how many
characters and how much time that's this
the thing too is going through the
villain puppet II and I was like oh wow
they have covered a whole lot of people
yeah you know it felt like the last
moments of them just all talking with
each other the villains and heroes was
the nostalgia fest we all kind of want
it yeah it was like a more animated
version of the shawarma scene I was
really happy with this I was very
surprised there's no surprises even if
the jokes aren't fully landing for you
you still get a good narrative out of it
it's just big a beat Joe alright guys
well thanks hizzy for putting together
some awesome awesome stuff you guys can
subscribe to his E of course you have
and yeah it took us out - see you later